(man) the sharks are back
in an all-New season
of "Shark tank,"
where Hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
I want to make it
so that people believe
that America can make products
that are great.
If the sharks
hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
How would I get
my money back?
I will write you a check.
(laughter)
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You're hurting children.
Are you kidding me?
We're not here to suck
the blood out of companies.
At what point
do you ever
get your money back?
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I don't wanna tell you
how to do this business,
I want to support you.
It's sink...
money's binary.
Either you make it,
or you lose it.
Or swim.
I know what has to be done.
When? When? When?
Right now.
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban,
notorious
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas mavericks.
First into the tank
are Susie and Steve Taylor,
who believe they've created
a better version
of something all babies need.
♪♪
Hi, sharks.
My name is Susie Taylor,
and this is my husband.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Steve Taylor.
Our company is bibbitec,
and we're here today
seeking $40,000
for a 14% stake
in our company.
As a parent
of two messy little boys,
we often found ourselves
in messy situations.
And what drove me insane
was Susie spending
our hard-Earned money
on bibs that just
didn't work.
So I pleaded with her,
"Susie, if they don't work,
please, don't buy them."
(laughs)
(laughs) okay.
So I stopped buying them,
and I decided
to solve the problem myself.
Introducing...
♪ ta-Da ♪
bibbitec.
The best thing
about the bibbitec bib
is the design.
It simply fits
over the child's arm
and slips over their head
and comfortably covers
their entire body.
(Susie) What's great about
this american-Made,
nontoxic fabric
is that it never stains,
never smells,
and never holds an odor.
It's too good to be True,
I know.
You wanna give 'em
a closer look?
Take a closer look, sharks?
Yeah.
I was hoping to see
the dirty one.
Could we have a look
at the dirty one?
(Steve) sure.
Oh, sure.
Susie, it didn't leave
a stain or anything on it?
It's just a little bit
of moisture from the wipe,
and it's gonna dry
with the air.
It's like fitness material.
Is this neoprene?
It's a poly-Nylon blend.
It's patented.
It's nontoxic certified.
It's comfortable.
The kids love to wear it.
What do you sell it for?
We are selling it right now,
direct to consumer,
on our web site, for $24.99.
What does it cost you
to make it?
Currently, our price
is $15 per bib.
Oh! Oh.
Oh, that's crazy.
Whoa.
That's brutal.
Holy cow!
But it is also selling
in catalogs online for $48.
Why is it $15 to make it?
Because This is
the Mack daddy material.
You can't make money
selling bibs to America
at a really high price.
It's cheaper to just
buy a bunch of bibs,
and throw them out
after they get dirty.
Absolutely not,
Mr. Wonderful.
This is one bib
that will last you
four years, even longer.
Once you look at what mothers
are buying on bibs...
what they're spending
a year--$400.
No. No way.
(Barbara) No way.
I will--
No way, Susie.
Okay, you don't notice it,
but you will throw away more
bibs than you can ever imagine.
How many have you sold?
We've sold about 2,000.
Over the four years?
Yes. Little under
four years.
What did you sell
in the last 12 months?
In the last 12 months,
uh, we are
at about 17,000,
uh, dollars in sales.
That's it?
The majority of bibs
are not bought online, guys.
Let's face it, okay?
Mm-hmm.
Millions of bibs
go out every year.
There's two or three
large-Box retailers
that sell baby apparel
like this.
Why are you not in retail?
Can I tell you why?
Yes, please do.
Okay. They said
it's a hard sell
because it's an education.
I have to explain
this bib actually works.
Ah.
Right.
They confirmed
that their bibs are bait.
They're used to get
the mom into the store
to buy the bib,
and the orange juice
and everything else...
But, Susie,
honey, sweetie, poopsie,
that's what I'm talking about.
I know, and--
It's too expensive.
No, it's not.
We have found that it has sold
at $48 without a question.
People are... I'm not...
$48? Insane.
It's ins--I could get
a whole outfit.
Of course. That's why
I pulled out of it.
And I feel retail
is obnoxious.
Susie, it's a Hobby.
It's not a business.
Well...
the numbers,
well, it start--
they're talking,
I'm listening.
Okay.
They're saying,
"Mr. Wonderful,
we're not selling very many,
cause they're too expensive."
I disagree. We have sold them
for all different prices.
The price is...
it really wasn't an issue.
The education of the product
is the issue.
I have no business experience.
I need you guys to blow me up.
Here's my challenge--
I actually think
it's a great product.
Thank you very much.
Instead of trying to sell it,
have you tried licensing it
to somebody
who already makes bibs?
Well, when I went
to the big box stores,
they all wanted me to go
to--to China.
They wanted me
to drag it down.
They wanted to sell it
for $19.99.
For me, the stuff
that I bought from China,
the toxins
that my kids were sucking on,
I couldn't morally do that.
I want to make it
so that people believe
that America can make products
that are great for our kids.
America can make products,
but your cost is keeping this
away from America.
But we're making
a mark--
You're hurting children
that don't get near it
because they can't afford it.
Well, our margins are large.
No. No. They're horrible.
They're terrible.
Margins are terrible.
Susie, you're making 'em
for $15,
you're selling 'em
for $24 on your web site.
Well...
How is that a good margin?
Robert, if I may,
whenever we get in front
of moms at trade shows...
it just...
if flies out.
When they see it...
and people flock around...
it flies out.
And they freak out.
Because they are
starting to realize
that they're buying stuff
from China, and it's breaking.
Are you making
any money doing this?
No.
We've invested over--
at the end of the four years,
about $75,000.
And you haven't made
any return
on that investment yet?
No.
What we feel
the value of our company is--
that we've been
out there to mothers,
we know
they love the product.
Steve, how long are you
going to lose money
every month doing this?
(sighs)
If we don't get
an investor,
I have a certain amount of money
I'm gonna put in,
that I'm willing
to put in.
How much more money
will you put in?
I think--
That we can afford,
personally?
We can't.
We can't afford any more.
So, Susie,
is it time to take the bib
behind the barn
and shoot it?
(gun cocks)
♪♪
So, Susie,
is it time to take the bib
behind the barn
and shoot it?
Absolutely not.
Can you get the price
of this bib down in America?
Yes. No question.
I think we can. If we have
a large order, we can.
Daymond, you gotta
make it for 2 bucks,
like every other bib's
made for.
What is the magic price point
to sell it at, retail-Wise?
We feel this one
can sell for $19.99.
We feel the larger one,
we feel a good price point
is either $24.99
or $29.99.
(daymond) Okay--
This is the first bib
they look at.
All right. So the $19.99 one
you have to manufacture
for $5.
(Kevin) That'll never happen.
We'd--We'd have to...
I...
get a different,
uh, material,
and we're open
for that.
(sighs heavily)
Steve, that's not
your problem.
Your problem is,
how do you sell many thousands?
And I don't think
you're doing a good job today
of explaining that.
'cause it's
too expensive, Robert.
Okay, well, let me ask you.
Susie, are you not
selling thousands
because it's too expensive?
No, I'm not
selling thousands--
So why are you not
selling thousands?
Because I'm just--
I'm a mom. My kids come first.
Sorry, Susie.
You're not selling more
because you're a mom?
No! Because
I don't have more time.
I'm just myself.
(lowered voice)
Deep breath. Deep breath.
We haven't gotten the message
out to all the mothers.
Susie, you've been
doing it for four years.
Susie, why are you
getting emotional
about this right now?
I'm a stay-at-Home mom,
trying to do my best,
really trying
to raise the kids
the way I was
"supposed" to raise the kids.
And Stephen was trying
to run a business.
And we would have
these fights over finances.
And one day,
we're on a-a road trip,
and he's asking about
the credit card bills.
And I'm trying
to explain to him
what the things are
that we need.
And there were a lot of bibs.
I know it's crazy,
but there were a lot of bibs.
And he's like, "where are they?"
and I'm like,
"They're in the garbage."
He's like, "suse,
that's hard-Earned money
you're throwing away."
(pats hands)
I'm like,
"But they don't work."
And I feel like it's--It's
like an endless pit of moms.
We're sitting here
trying to do our best
with products
that aren't working,
and that's where
the passion comes from.
I'm--I'm heartbroken.
Do you think
we're not astute investors?
W--Wait a second.
We're looking at it
from the side that matters--
the money.
You're not making any.
You're losing your family's
money every month.
Do you think
any investor up here
wants to join you
in that madness?
We don't have
your connections.
Money's binary--Either you
make it, or you lose it.
There's a tipping point,
okay?
We are at
that tipping point.
To say that
we haven't made money...
and my question be--
has been...
it's not fair
to say we'll never make it.
When? When? When?
Right now!
Okay. Guys, guys, guys,
guys, guys, guys.
With one of you,
or all of you.
There's no point.
It's like--
right.
It's like arguing with--
With... a wall.
Here's my perspective--
I like the product.
Thank you.
I don't think
you need to sell it retail.
I don't have a problem
with the price point.
Thank you.
I think there's
a large enough market there.
What I do have
a problem with is,
you're not
the right person to run it.
You're the exact
wrong person to run it.
Go find a college kid
who knows internet marketing,
and takes it out to all
the different moms' groups.
Cost you $25,000, $30,000
for that person to do it.
It's not about connections.
I'm not the right solution.
It's out there for you.
I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
Um, I agree
with mark's very good idea,
and that's easily done.
But I also think you have
a ready-Made
mom sales force out there.
I think you could get
a legion of moms
believing as fervently
as you do in the product,
which is so obvious.
And I think you could
very inexpensively
get your product out there
where it belongs,
and I don't think
it's retail.
That's a great idea.
Thank you. Thank you.
My instincts
Have always served me well,
so on this one,
I'm out.
They've lied to you.
They are giving you
encouragement where there's
none, and I'm disgusted.
I'm out.
Daymond, Robert, any...
the challenge
I'm having here is that
in most businesses,
the problem
is the education.
I can't help you
educate people about bibs.
I'm out.
I hear a lot
of confusing strategies
on how to sell it.
What I've learned is,
you gotta follow the money.
I don't think
you have a clear plan
on how to make this successful.
I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Thanks a lot, guys.
Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
Thanks.
I don't think I'm ever
gonna give up.
Moms need better products,
and I'm gonna
give it to them.
♪♪
(clucking)
My name is Moshe Weiss.
I live in st. Paul, minnesota,
with my wife and three kids.
(children laughing)
Besides being a full-Time
father and husband...
(speaking hebrew)
I'm also a rabbi.
Today we are gonna be
talking about kosher.
Being a rabbi takes faith
and a lot of belief,
and I try to bring that
in my business as well.
What do you think
of my invention?
Great!
We live in
a world of technology,
where everyone is connected.
My product helps people use
that technology better.
They might not even know
that they need it,
but when they use it,
it's gonna be...
(high-Pitched, singsong voice)
Awesome!
♪♪
Shalom, sharks.
My name is rabbi Moshe Weiss.
My product
is the soundbender.
I'm here to offer you guys
26% of my company...
(Robert laughs)
For only $54,000.
Wow.
Uh-huh. A deal.
You might be asking yourself,
what's a rabbi
doing on "Shark tank"?
(laughs)
Well, I'm gonna tell you.
As a rabbi, I'm always
looking to help people
and find solutions
for them.
I'm always trying
to make their "Oy Vey"...
go away.
(laughter)
All right?
So I felt it was
my obligation
to come here today
and ask you for help
in solving
a very real dilemma.
A dilemma...
(laughter)
That, dare I say,
is so rampant,
it could be affecting
over 70 million people
worldwide.
Oy vey.
Oy vey, big time.
(laughter)
So what's this big problem,
right?
Well, I'll tell you.
I love my ipad.
(laughter)
I love it so much.
I watch videos on it.
I play music on it.
I love it.
But since the speaker
is pointing away from me
if I was watching it here,
right?
And you can't grab that sound
and bring it towards your ears,
where you need to hear it.
So I invented my product.
And today, sharks,
I am very proud to present
the solution to
this very great dilemma...
the soundbender.
(laughter)
Magnetic, power-Free
amplifier for your ipad.
It clips right on
to the back magnetically,
beautifully reflecting
the sound right towards you--
Boom--Just like that,
in a snap.
Wow.
All right, check this out.
(klezmer band playing
"Hava nagila")
(laughs)
(Robert) Oy.
♪♪
(volume increases)
Oh, wow.
Stop the madness.
It's magical.
It makes a real difference.
It really does.
It's awesome.
This little baby--
Not only does it offer
huge sound,
it also offers huge margins.
Hey, come on.
Rabbis gotta eat, too, right?
(laughs)
Moshe, very good presentation.
Very easy to understand.
Tell us about
those succulent margins
you made reference to.
Um, what would you
like to know?
What are they?
I'd like to know
the numbers.
Well, it costs right now,
without packaging, a dollar.
Including the magnets?
Including the magnets,
my friend.
Okay, and how much
are you selling it for?
$12.99 retail--Manufacturer's
suggested retail price.
$12.99?
Ooh, rabbi.
$12.99, baby.
A higher power is involved.
Moshe, are you
selling it today?
I am.
Do you have sales?
I do have sales.
I've sold 7,000 units
to date.
I've only been selling it
for about six months.
Where are you selling it?
How? Online?
I'm selling them online,
and actually, um,
to a wholesale online...
do you have those
for us to look at?
Yes, I do.
I have several of them.
Which color would you like?
I have pink...
Oh, colors.
White, for sure.
(Robert) Oh.
White?
I'm gonna take red and black.
Stop and go.
Okay.
And I have more, so...
thank you, sir.
Appreciate it.
It's cool. All right.
Thank you.
Moshe, I gotta know--
How did you come up
with the idea?
Oh, man, I'm a teacher,
a rabbi,
at a-a jewish high school
for--for boys
out in minnesota,
and we had to close it down.
You know, the recession just
literally destroyed us.
And somebody gave me
an ipad as a gift,
to lift my spirits.
So I started using it
at night,
and I kept cupping
my hand behind it,
and then I just...
it was like...
it was like--It was like a light
at the end of the tunnel.
And within a week,
I had prototypes.
I-I've been working
with the same manufacturer
in minnesota.
Made in the U.S.A.
And the margins
are still amazing.
It's just been
a really great experience.
I really--I'm here today
to ask for your help
because I'm willing
to work hard.
What do you want
the $54,000 for?
What are you
gonna do with it?
I am going to modify
the mold one more time.
Why? It works great
right now.
It does, but I want it
to work better.
Are you the kind of guy
that wants to keep tinkering
and not sell?
No, absolutely not.
I want to sell and...
make it better
so we can sell more.
Sometimes people
have that disease,
they never stop
trying to make it better.
Yeah, I don't have
that disease.
I'll tell you what--
I have, um, very,
very high interest
from a very large
retail chain.
Um...
who is it?
Walgreens.
Walgreens?
Yeah.
Rabbi, would you be against
licensing your idea
to somebody that could get
overnight distribution
to millions of outlets,
millions of units,
drive your production cost
down to pennies?
I mean, I look
at the accessories market.
It's a $2 billion business.
It's huge.
But it's not made
in kitchen tables.
It's hundreds
of thousands of units
pounded out of a mold
in Asia.
To me, the opportunity here
is to try and convince somebody
to give you 4 cents a unit,
just in a royalty,
and run with it.
That, to me,
is the way I would do it.
But I don't think
I sense that from you.
I'll tell you
very straightforward,
I am not going to license it out
for 4 cents apiece
and bang 'em out
in China.
Okay, rabbi,
I'm out.
I respect that.
Thank you very much.
There's four other sharks.
Let's negotiate, people.
Let's get this done.
Rabbi, I-I think you've got
a nice little business here.
You've got the chutzpah.
(giggles)
but I've gotta make
the determination of my time,
right,
which is very valuable.
If I saw a way to get this
to a $20 million-In-Sales
business,
then it's worth--
I-I just don't see it getting
that big. I really don't.
So for that reason, I'm out.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
How would I get
my money back
if I gave you
the money for this product?
I will write you a check.
When?
(laughter)
That's a start.
It couldn't be simpler
than that, Barbara.
I'm suggesting a guarantee
that I get my money back
as you sell.
So you want a royalty?
Well, sort of a royalty, yeah.
I-I think that might be
counterproductive
to what I'm trying
to do.
Why?
So that's off the table?
Because it's
siphoning off cash
while we're
growing the business.
Don't you think
that it would make sense--
No, I don't think
that's a problem.
Well done.
Well done, rabbi.
Okay. I'm out.
(daymond) I can't negotiate
lower money.
So what do you think we need
to negotiate here?
Obviously, you would like
to possibly negotiate
the percentage
of the company?
A-Cha.
How much of the company
would you be willing
to be okay with
for the $54,000,
sticking at that?
I would be happy
with 40%.
The only thing
that is out there
that's making me want
to invest in this company
is the walgreens sale.
Here's my offer,
to clarify--
$54,000, 40%,
and it has to be that
that walgreens sale
is a real deal.
Okay.
That's my offer.
(exhales) Um, Robert?
Would you like to...
you know, Moshe,
you're one of the best
entrepreneurs we've had here.
I mean, you gave us the best
answer anybody's ever given
when we asked
for this royalty stuff.
Doesn't mean
it's the right answer.
It's the right answer.
No, it isn't.
We're not here to suck
the blood out of companies.
At what point do you
ever get your money back?
Moshe, I gave you an offer.
If we're gonna listen
to them too much longer...
right.
'cause you understand,
if he steps out...
right.
My offer starts to change,
because I become more valuable.
Uh, are you going
to make an offer, Robert?
I-I hate to...
♪♪
three sharks are out.
Rabbi Moshe has an offer
on the table from daymond,
and Robert is still
considering the investment.
Moshe, I gave you an offer.
Yes.
If we're gonna listen
to them too much longer...
right.
'cause you understand,
if he steps out...
right.
My offer starts to change,
because I become more valuable.
Are you going
to make an offer, Robert?
I-I hate to...
here's the good--
I love the reason
you started this business.
I think you're highly motivated,
I think you did
a fantastic presentation.
Let's do it.
Here's the bad...
(laughs)
Beyond the presentation,
you didn't really tell us
how we're gonna sell it.
You didn't talk about
the distribution channel.
My biggest fear is,
as mark said, is my time.
I don't wanna tell you
how to do this business.
I want to support you.
I know
what has to be done.
I'm not sitting
on my hands going,
(yiddish accent) "oy gevalt,
I don't know what to do."
(laughter)
"what am I gonna do? Hey."
You know,
I can sit at home
and I can relax and I can
make a nice living
and sell my soundbenders
a thousand at a time
on the internet-Schminternet.
Yeah!
Schminternet.
Whatever, whatever.
(normal voice) I know how
to do this business.
I need your connections.
That's what I need.
I'd like to make an offer.
Okay.
I'd like to hear
your answer on Daymond's offer.
I'm gonna give you
ten seconds to think about it.
After that, I'm dropping out.
I'll give you the $54,000.
Same amount. 40%.
I'm gonna take you at your word
that the walgreens order's
there.
Same offer as daymond.
So let's summarize--
Both offers are for
the same amount of equity, 40%,
for the same amount
of dollars--$54,000.
One has a contingency,
the other doesn't.
What are you going
to do?
Daymond, we have a deal.
My man.
Congratulations.
All right.
We got a deal. We got a deal,
and we're gonna make money.
You're gonna
really help me.
I just wanted to see
if you could
close walgreens.
Really, you're...
other than that...
you're really
an awesome person.
It's gonna close.
I got it.
We'll get it done.
Adios.
(laughs)
Is "Adios" Yiddish?
(Barbara) No.
(laughter)
I chose daymond because
he is a marketing genius.
He's--he's built his company
from one product
to millions of products sold,
and, um, I really have
a lot of respect for him,
and I think he got that.
♪♪
Earlier this season,
Jim tselikis and Sabin lomac
made a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for their food truck company,
cousins maine lobster.
Barbara,
welcome to the family.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
♪♪
Let's Crank
these orders out!
Two pack of live lobsters!
So much has happened
since we did a deal with Barbara
just a couple months ago.
Keep 'em pumpin'!
we have just opened
a 7,000-Square-Foot
distribution facility so we can
ship fresh maine products
to everyone in
the United States overnight.
We just hit 2,000 orders
for the day!
(cheering)
Sales have been awesome
since "Shark tank."
A few months
before we went on,
we did $150,000 in business.
Ever since, we've done
$700,000 in sales.
Hey, Jim, Sabin!
Hey!
Barbara is truly
the best thing
that has happened
to this company.
She is so hands-On
and genuine with us,
and she's provided us
opportunities
that other businesses
would dream of.
We've been so good to our local
economy here in maine,
we've actually been invited
to the governor's home
to receive an award
from the first lady.
"This is a certificate
of achievement
"presented
to cousins maine lobster
"in recognition of
outstanding accomplishments
and contributions."
I've invested in a lot of
businesses on "Shark tank,"
and I have great entrepreneurs,
but this is the first time
I've ever been given an award
for creating jobs
in a local economy.
It's honestly the greatest thing
that's happened so far.
We love the fact that you're
creating great jobs
for the people
in the state of maine.
So keep 'em coming.
Thank you.
Our company
is growing so fast.
We've got Barbara on our team,
and this is proof that we are
doing something right,
and that's really
a good feeling.
Thank you, "Shark Tank"!
next up is Mike Robinson,
who believes his product
helps children
feel close to their loved ones.
♪♪
Hi, sharks.
I'm Mike Robinson,
C.E.O. Of cuddletunes.
We're seeking $400,000
for a 20% stake in the company.
Cuddletunes is
a product and service
born out of personal need.
See, for the past 20 years,
I've been a business traveler
constantly on the road
all over the world.
But at the same time,
I'm very devoted to my seven
Beautiful children at home.
And when you're away a lot,
it really takes a toll
on your relationships
with Small Children
or grandchildren.
You feel the distance,
and they feel it, too.
Well, we can help.
Sharks, you know all
about the world wide web.
Let me introduce you
to the worldwide hug.
This bear is gonna help
millions of families stay closer
and change bedtime forever.
Inside cuddletunes is
a web-Connected audio player.
So you can send
your recorded voice
to your child
or grandchild's bear
from anywhere, anytime.
This is my daughter Mia's bear.
(Click)
(Mike) Hi, Mia, sweetheart.
Tonight I'm gonna
tell you a new story.
Once upon a time,
there were
three caterpillars...
in addition
to your recorded voice,
cuddletunes plays mp3 music...
(Click, narration stops)
Which can be personalized
with the child's name.
(woman) ♪ Hush, little Mia ♪
♪ don't make a peep ♪
as you can hear,
the sound quality is terrific,
and it's incredibly
simple to operate.
Through our easy-to-Use
Web site,
from anywhere in the world,
parents and grandparents
can record Anything they want--
Prayers, stories, songs,
Loving messages,
and they can upload mp3 music
and audio books.
And your child can enjoy
all of that on their bear,
whenever they need it.
Sharks, with over $1 million
in development behind us,
the product and service
are ready to go.
And I need your help
to scale this up
into a global family brand.
Can I offer you a bear?
Did you say you spent a million
dollars in development?
Allowing for the three years'
effort, yes.
What do you mean, "allowing
for the three years"?
paying yourself
for the effort?
What does that mean?
What's that?
Yeah, valuing my time
at a big discount...
Ah.
Actually, compared
to what I--
How much money
have you actually
put into the business?
In terms of cash?
Yeah.
Uh, about half a million.
Wow.
(woman singing indistinctly)
Mike, how do I hook up
the bear to the internet?
It's got--in the back
is the mp3 player,
and it has a usb connection.
So you plug it
into your computer,
and just like you sync
an ipod to itunes,
you sync a cuddletunes bear
to cuddletunes.
It's a very simple process.
You don't even have to
install any software.
What do you value
your time at?
I was making $300,000 a year
as a public company C.E.O.
What company
were you c.E.O. Of?
It was called
citel technologies.
It was a voice over I.P. Company
in the U.K.,
and I took it public
on the London exchange in 2006.
And what happened
to that company?
Did you leave, or...
Uh, about a year and a half
after the I.P.O.,
um, the board and I...
had different visions.
So they fired you.
No, they offered me
a deal.
And, uh, I had already been
talking to some friends
about this idea.
Mike...
Yeah?
My--My only pet peeve,
I'll tell you,
is I-I hate when people
value their time...
Mm-hmm.
When they're starting
a start-up.
That--That's your cost.
That's an opportunity cost...
Absolutely. Yeah.
Not my cost.
So I--
I'm not asking you to--
I'm not asking you
to pay me for that time.
But you did say--
You did say--
I'm just asking you
to recognize
that that's the value
of the business.
So you--You've put
a $2 million valuation
on this business
right now.
Yes.
Are you saying you've got
sales to support that,
or just your time?
If you don't mind,
I'd like to come back to that.
Well, generally, that means
you have no sales.
(Robert chuckles)
Always a bad answer.
First I'd like you
to understand--
Mike, when somebody doesn't
answer the sales question,
usually, all of us
get really uncomfortable.
Well, let me ask you this--
So we launched this thing,
did no marketing,
and then 32,000 people
have been to the site.
How many units
do you think we would have sold?
I would think 5% of them
would have bought it.
Yeah. It's 9 1/2%.
Over 3,000 units sold.
Ooh.
It's brought in
about $90,000.
Has that been consistent
every month, 9% conversion?
It depends on where
the traffic comes from.
So a good deal of that
has come from deals
that we've run
with livingsocial and groupon,
where we didn't
have to pay any marketing...
Oh, that--Okay,
that just kills
the whole
conversion percentage.
(daymond) Yeah.
That's just
a discount mechanism,
and they do
all the promoting.
It's not your site
doing the promoting.
Right. Well, that's the point,
is that somebody else
went out there
and spent their money
to tell somebody about this
and present them
with an offer.
But this is what they do.
Groupon--
That's what they do.
They do that to everybody.
It's their job.
They... right.
What did you make per bear
on a groupon deal?
We're only at about
20% margin on that.
And you gave them
a discount?
Yes, the consumer
gets a discount.
What did you present
the retail as,
what did you sell it
through the deal company,
and what are your costs
for this?
The--the bear itself
is $39.95.
That's the retail price?
Yes.
And then people pay
an EXTRA 20 bucks
for personalized music
and a year of unlimited
recording and downloads.
So the bundle is 60 bucks.
How much did groupon
and livingsocial sell it for
to their customers?
Their usual, half off.
If you just
kept that model,
you wouldn't have
a sustainable business,
because your margins
are only 20%.
Right, but of course, I'm not
gonna keep that model.
Mike, when I was a kid,
we had ten kids in our family,
so my dad sang and played
the guitar to us every night.
Right.
And he came up
with the genius idea
of recording his voice
and all of his songs.
Yeah.
We all had
a funny reaction to it.
Really?
We all felt so sad,
because my dad wasn't there
doing it for us.
Interesting.
So it was kind of
a freaky experience.
Hmm.
And it was eliminated
in our household
probably within a month.
Yeah.
So I don't think
This is gonna work.
I'm out.
Thank you
for your time.
Mike, I'm just
trying to be clear--
I can record my voice
to my kids
within a stuffed animal.
What's your distinct advantage?
And you can send it to them
from anywhere in the world.
So not only you,
But the grandparents
that don't live nearby
can be doing it.
You can be updating
stuff continually,
you can...
so the only advantage is,
I can attach yours
to the internet and update it?
Correct, which means
you don't have to be there
to put your voice on it.
Mike, I just don't
see anything unique here.
I don't think that being able
to record to the cloud
is anything
significantly differentiated.
(rips)
I'm out.
Okay. Thanks, mark.
Mike, I don't think
your being able to update
is that big a deal.
I'm out.
Okay, thanks, Robert.
So, um...
if I invested my money
in this,
I'd sleep like a baby.
I'd wake up
every two hours, crying,
and asking my mommy,
"where's my money?"
I'm out.
So, Kevin...
Yes, Mike?
The power of this product
is in the emotional proposition.
And what's missing
in your presentation--
I'm not even gonna fight you
on valuation at this point,
because it wouldn't matter
if you're asking
for a $2 million value or 10.
You don't know what
your customer acquisition Cost
is going to be in a sustained
model. You just don't.
Right.
There's no way I would
give you $400,000.
I'm out.
Thanks for your time.
Good luck.
Okay.
Don't trust him as far
as I could throw him.
As I could throw him.
He looked at us
like one big honey pot.
I know. He's so slick.
I think this thing
is foaming at the mouth.
(laughter)
♪♪
(man) ♪ Ooh, aah ♪
♪ ooh, aah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
I'm Steven sashen, and this is
my beautiful Wife Lena Phoenix.
And we live
in Boulder, colorado.
Some people think boulder
is just a bunch of aging,
long-Haired hippie athletes.
And they're right, and we are
their spokespeople. (laughs)
I'm a competitive sprinter,
so when I got back
into sprinting
after a 30-year break,
I was injured constantly,
and a friend suggested
that taking off my shoes
might be a cure.
So I did, and it was.
And I've been basically
Barefoot ever since.
This new Hobby of mine
inspired our new business,
and we haven't looked back.
Our product
is kind of deceptive
in that it looks
really simple,
but it's actually
part of a revolution.
We want to change the world.
So we're hoping the sharks
will really understand
what the power of this is.
We have pretty much
given up our entire lives
for this product for the last
two and a half years.
If we don't get an investment
from the sharks,
we're gonna be exactly
where we are right now--
In over our heads
with a great product
that we don't know how
to get out into the world
while our inferior competitors
just run right past us.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Lena Phoenix, and I am
the owner of xero shoes.
And I'm Steven sashen.
I'm the C.E.O.
We're looking for $400,000
in exchange for
8% equity in our company.
Wow.
40 years after the invention
of the heavily padded,
very expensive running shoe,
research is showing
how just your feet,
without all the bells
and whistles,
can do a better job.
But Barefoot
is not always appropriate.
That's why I developed
xero shoes
original barefootware.
Xero shoes
are a high-Tech version
of mankind's favorite footwear
since 15,000 B.C.
(Lena) Xero shoes
are the only footwear
that have been shown
in Independent university study
to be biomechanically
identical to Barefoot
plus a layer of protection.
Xero shoes let you
express your personality
with styles that range from
high-Performance ultra-Minimal
to night-on-the-Town
fashion-Forward.
(Lena)
They're also super lightweight,
way more comfortable
than flip-Flops,
and unlike some other
Barefoot shoes,
they never smell.
Now before you jump
out of your chairs
and rush the table to get
your hands and feet on a pair,
Lena will do
her best Vanna white
and deliver some.
(chuckles)
Steve, are you saying
you can run in Those?
Uh, not only can you,
I'm a masters
all-American sprinter,
so I'm one of the fastest
50-year-Olds in America.
Really?
You can run in these?
That shoe that you have
was designed by a guy
who runs 50-Mile ultra marathons
on a regular basis.
We designed our first
custom-Made xero shoe pendant.
Kevin, I want to start with you
just to see
what you think of it.
Thank you very much.
Oh, that's
extremely attractive.
(laughs)
I had a hunch
you might like it.
Yes, I do.
They've somehow captured
the essence of an athlete.
Robert, since you have
this skeptical tone
in your voice...
(Barbara laughs)
why don't you come up,
if you want to,
join us, and you can
actually experience it.
'cause feeling
xero Shoes is one thing,
But wearing them--
That's a whole different story.
Plus I'm the only
runner up here.
So what I'm gonna do is,
on one foot, I'm gonna
give you our 4mm connect.
This is the closest thing
there is to Barefoot
plus a layer of protection.
And on the other foot,
I'm gonna do our 6mm contact,
gives you
a little smoother ride,
little--for people who want
a little extra cushion.
And are they custom-Made?
We sell them
in two different ways--
Either as
a do-It-Yourself kit
that you can trim down
to your unique foot shape,
um, or we can
custom-Make them for you.
There's, like,
nothing to it.
Yeah. Well...
it doesn't feel like
you've got anything on.
You don't need
a lot of support.
Putting your foot in support
is like putting
your feet in a cast
and expecting them
to get stronger.
So when you walk
across our fake world...
(daymond) Robert...
and get to feel
the world...
Wait, let me
light the coals first.
(laughter)
Ouch, ouch.
The one on your left
is the closest to Barefoot,
the one on your right gives you
a little smoother ride.
It's like getting
a little foot massage, yeah?
Ye--Oh, yeah.
Okay, Well, rob,
how do you feel?
I gotta tell you,
they feel great.
(laughs)
No, seriously, I know
they look weird, but...
(daymond) So I don't want
to state the obvious,
but you basically come over here
with some rubber and a string
and you said it's worth
$5 million.
That's correct.
Um, why do you feel that?
We started this business
two and a half years ago.
Uh, with just a web site.
No advertising.
And since that time,
we've sold over $650,000
of our do-It-Yourself
sandal kits
and custom-Made...
in two years?
In two and a half years.
The last 2 months, we've done
a little over $130,000.
Just alone, so...
So things are
going like this.
This year we're on track
for about $1.2 million.
Yeah.
On the $1.2 million, if you
hit it this year in sales,
what will your profits be?
We're projecting
$200,000 for this year.
What's it cost to make?
What's it cost to sell?
What we sell the most of is
our 4mm, uh, do-It-yourself kit,
which retails for $24.95.
Our cost of materials
is $3.11.
What do you wholesale it for?
Uh, $12.97.
And what percent
is sold through Retail
or other distribution,
and what percent
is sold through your web site?
Over 90% is sold--
Sold through our web site.
We are just starting,
uh, in retail.
We've got nine
retail locations currently.
Six of them
have already reordered.
(Robert) tell you, to me,
I open it up,
and it looks like
just a plain piece of plastic.
Like a broken sneaker.
Yeah.
(laughter)
(Kevin) You're gonna
make $200,000
if everything goes right
this year.
You're asking me to pay you
25 times that amount
and value your business
at 25 times profit.
That's correct.
But here's the other problem
I've got--
If this category is growing
as fast as you say...
right.
It's going to attract some very
big competitors at some point.
Yeah.
And will look down at this
and say,
"Mm. Piece of rubber.
Piece of string."
Right.
"I can do the same thing
"And put my distribution power
behind it
and crush
these cockroaches."
Well, first of all,
we do have a design patent,
uh, pending on these.
But it's a piece of rubber
and a string.
It's more than that.
Steve, I promise you that
I can have these on the boat
in about 30 days.
Oh, I would
challenge you for that one.
You want to challenge me?
You cut a piece of rubber,
put a string on it,
and you said that This is
great technology.
And then you say
the company's worth $5 million,
and you've only done...
no, we say the company's
worth $5 million
because of
our industry experts.
Because of what?
The industry?
I'm out.
Steve, were you a shoe guy?
No, no, no.
Like, how do you
wake up one day
and say,
"I'm gonna make..."
hold that thought.
The tarahumara indians
in mexico--
They did
their own version of this.
I mean, this is, again,
a 15,000-year-Old idea.
This is...
the tarahumara indians
in mexico
are a people
who are known for running
50, 60, 70 miles at a stretch
wearing nothing But sandals
made out of scraps of tire
and bits of leather.
Look, it's a huge
leap of faith.
I believe
your whole granola story,
and the indians
running around
in the desert
and all that stuff.
(laughs)
But on the other hand,
it's a crapshoot.
I'll--I'll make you an offer
just for the Heck of it.
I'll give you
the $400,000 for 50%.
Okay.
You're worth about
800 grand, that's it.
Okay. Thank you.
We'll come back to you on that.
So back to some--
Wait, you need
to come back to him on that?
Oh, well, it's not an offer
that I would take
right off the bat.
We value the equity much higher
than that at this point.
Well, I know that, but that's
why you're in the shark tank.
True.
You're here for money.
I'm a rational investor.
You people are probably
delusional entrepreneurs.
Perhaps.
And somewhere in the middle
is reality.
Okay, uh, first off,
you give me a headache.
I don't know why.
Oh, sorry.
You remind me
of my first husband.
You're a little Shorter,
but there's a similarity.
(laughs)
and there's two things
driving me crazy--
One is,
it's a black sole...
well...
Which is hot.
Secondly, it's got
a knot on the bottom.
I would think
it would be uncomfortable,
and that's a liability,
all right?
So I'm not crazy
about the product.
I have to be honest.
I'm out.
I love this stuff.
I'm a big runner.
I'm getting old,
my knees hurt,
I've tried everything.
This would be
the thing to try.
Steve,
I would love to try it.
Sure.
But $400,000, giving
the company a $5 million value,
man, I can't try
for that price.
I'm out.
Thank you.
You have an offer
from somebody that's rational.
It's True.
And I don't have
a shoe company in my portfolio.
And I think your story--
I'm listening to it,
it's got a shtick, and it's
a--really a marketing strategy.
Yeah.
You've got rubber
and string.
Yeah.
And I'm willing to say
it's worth $800,000.
I'd give you $400,000 for 50%.
It's a clean deal.
50% is way beyond
what we're willing to do.
What's your counter?
Uh, my counter would be 10%.
You're out of your mind.
One of the other companies
that's also in this space
recently, uh, got $10 million
for 25% of their company
based on the--a multiple
of their projections
for the following year.
First of all, because
one of your competitors
got someone to put money in
at a ridiculous valuation
doesn't make that
a comp for you guys.
It just means you're competing
against someone
that's got
stupid money behind them.
Do you know what they call
a bunch of investors
rushing into a hot area,
like you've mentioned,
with all these
other investors?
They call it a bubble.
And no one's a bigger expert
at getting out of a bubble
at the right time
than I am,
so I'm telling you,
you should take Kevin's deal,
because your bubble
is going to pop.
I'm out.
Okay. There are no other
sharks here.
Correct.
There's just you, me, Lena,
the rubber, and the string.
What are you going to do?
I'm gonna give you $400,000
for 50% of this company.
That's an offer we're not
willing to take at this time.
Very well.
You're dead to me.
Run out of here
in bare feet.
(laughter)
(daymond) Thank you, guys.
Thank you for your time.
Thanks. Pleasure. Thanks.
Now that we're dead to Kevin,
we're gonna have to show him
that he made the wrong decision.
We have so many people
who love our product
and have experienced
Real benefits from it.
We know that this is something
that there's a real market for,
and we're just gonna continue
to do what we do.